Hello and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
You may remember recently we did a video
on Scribe Security.
They offer a platform
that allows you to collect evidence,
visualize that evidence and understand the supply chain
of your software. What we didn't cover in
that video is that Scribes Security's platform also
has a command line application
called Valint.
And we're gonna take a look at using
Valint today
to collect that evidence and store it. Not
only that, we're gonna take a look at
enforcing policies
to make sure that your software and supply
chain are up to scratch. So let's take
a quick look at the scribe security documentation
for Valant.
Okay. Here we have the documentation.
As I said, Valant is a command line
application.
Why is this interesting? Well, it means you
can run everything you're about to see locally
just as I am running it locally on
my machine. Not only that, because it's just
a command line application,
you can run it in your CICD pipeline.
You want to run Valant and GitHub actions?
Go for it. Valant can even be run
as an admission controller within a Kubernetes cluster,
allowing you to enforce policies that verify
your supply chain at runtime and production. So
how do we get started? Well, the documentation
has two ways to get access to Valant.
Number one, curl and pipe to your shell.
You can grab it from get.scrapesecurity.com/install.sh,
where if you put that through a shell,
you will get your Valant in your local
directory. Or you can pull the Valiant container
image from their JFrog instance, which is scrapesecurity.jfrog.i0/scrape-docker-public-local/
valiant latest. Of course, all of this will
be in the documentation and we will make
links to it in the show notes below.
So you don't have to listen to me
read out slashes, dashes, and all sorts in
between. However, get yourself access to Valent and
you can follow along with this tutorial. So
as I said, Valent allows you to collect
evidence to help you build out supply chain
security posture.
That evidence can come from Python or from
PyPI as we can see on the support
table here. It also comes from NPM,
from Go, from Docker,
from Red Hat, Java, Debian, and so forth.
Hopefully, that covers a good portion of the
landscape of the runtimes and programming languages that
you're using and the operating systems or technologies
you use to deploy. As far as evidence
goes,
course, we have access to nest,
segstore,
CVEs,
etcetera. And the really cool thing about what
we're gonna show with Valiant today, I think
you don't need to push that evidence to
scribe security, although you should with that very
generous feature we covered in the previous video.
But you can actually store that evidence inside
of an OCI artifact itself,
and we'll be doing that on today's tutorial.
And again, because it's a command line application
and there are GitHub actions available,
you can run this on GitHub actions as
part of your CICD
process.
Okay. So why don't we generate a bill
of materials for a container image? What do
I mean by that? Well, we want to
start collecting some evidence. We want to pull
down an image, understand how it's built, and
generate that bill of materials. And we can
do that with Valiant.
So step one is obviously just make sure
you've downloaded and have access to the Valiant
command line.
Once you do, you have access to the
Valiant BOM command.
We can type help on that. There's a
whole bunch of options to help you start
collecting
all of your evidence.
So let's do Valiant BOM.
Now you get to choose the output format
that you wish to store it.
I'm gonna do a test
Salsa, although we'll cover more options in just
a moment. Lastly, provide a container image that
you want to collect and store the evidence
for.
For me, let's do Alpine latest.
This pulls on the image and then will
give you a prompt to ensure that you're
happy to publish the evidence to the transparency
log.
Let's hit yes
and this will ask me to log in
with Segstor.
And done. Alright. So let's go through this
in just a little bit more detail. First,
we have said that we want to generate
billing materials for Alpine latest. We see here
that Valint
will actually pull down the image from the
remote registry. In this case, that is Docker
Hub. We can also see that it collects
some context, which is type local. And that's
just because I'm running the command line application
locally on my own machine. Valiant has knowledge
and awareness of other contexts such as GitHub,
GitLab, and so forth. And we'll see a
list of them in a moment when we
head back to the documentation.
Then you'll see we get a little bit
of a pop up asking us to confirm
that we're happy for some information to be
stored in the transparency log.
So why did this happen? Because we did
an dash o, a test salsa, the default
attestation
is with Sigstore. If we run v a
l n dash dash help and scroll up
to here,
you'll see that dash dash test default
supports x five zero nine, Segstor GitHub or
Segstor with Segstor being the default. That just
means that our information will be published to
the public transparency log and signed with Segstor.
Once that's all done, we're now in a
position where we can actually take a look
and verify the information that we generated and
that verification step includes any policies that we
define.
So let's run v lint verify
and we set the input format, which will
be the same as the output format we
used earlier.
We can then say that we want to
verify the bill of materials with Alpine latest
image.
As you can see, this pulled this down
from the public record and we have a
cache stored in our local directory
and it also verifies the certificate authority
that signed this information. As you can see,
we already have a policy called Rawkode only
applied which passed
and we'll take a look at that in
just a moment too.
Let's talk about that environment context.
When I ran it on my local machine,
the context was local.
Why?
Well, because I ran the command of my
own personal machine. However,
when you're generating your bill of materials, it's
more likely that this will run-in an automated
environment
such as your CICD pipeline.
As you can see here from this list,
that Valence supports and understands
various contexts.
It's likely you're probably using GitHub actions as
that's where a lot of open source and
even proprietary software development happens these days.
Of course, GitLab, Azure, Bitbucket, and so forth
are all very popular options and also provide
their own CICD environments.
When you build your build materials, you want
to suck up as much information from that
environment as possible, like the branch name, the
repository name, the committers, the tags, and so
forth.
And if we scroll down, you'll actually see
that as part of this environmental awareness,
Valid collects the URL, the branch, the commit,
the tag, even the workflow names and the
actors and the build number. So collecting this
information just means that you can build policies
to ensure that your production cluster only ever
runs workloads
where you can prove through evidence collection
that the build happened
on your CICD system
and signed with the keys that you expect.
So now let's talk about that policy.
So we can definite well, you should definitely
have a policy that ensures your proprietary software
only runs if it was built in your
CICD pipeline. However, you can get started with
policies much, much easier.
And say this directory, I have a valent
dot yaml. And say this, I have an
attestation cocosign
policy. This just means a cosign policy where
I have Rawkode only.
And we already seen this name run when
I ran the valent verify.
We have the enabled true flag just to
make sure this policy is enforced or
checked when we run a valent verify.
And then we can add one or more
modules to run as part of the policy.
Here, I have a module named Rawkode module
where the type is to verify the artifact.
We enable this and what we're seeing is
this artifact must be signed, must be in
the format a test salsa and the signer
identity must be one of these people and
in my case, I'm using myself,
which is david@rawkode.academy.
So let's change this policy
and break it. Let's say I use rawcode.com
and now we run valent
verify
dash I
test salsa
alpine
latest.
Again, this is going to check the evidence
creation within the public record, pull it down
to my machine, and then our policy runs
against the collected evidence. As you can see
here, the signature for this evidence was not
me, at least was not david@rockode.com.
This time, it goes, hey, actually,
this is signed by david@rockode.academy.
So you can see how powerful this would
be if your CICD system is configured
to say in something. You don't want another
workload not saying about identity running in your
cluster.
So let's understand evidence collection in a little
bit more detail by diving in to the
output itself.
Let's run valent BOM again with the attest
salsa output format.
This time, we're gonna set the output directory
to be evidence and again we'll run this
against the Halpine
latest. This is gonna make sure we have
the latest version of the image, collect all
the evidence, ask me to sign it once
more,
which we can do here and then it
will store all of the evidence that collected
into
the evidence directory.
As you can see here, we have a
cache dot JSON and
if we just cap this and throw it
through j q, we can see that local
context and the information that I collected.
This is the information that you can use
to build and enforce your policies.
And if you do this in GitHub, the
context will contain all that extra information such
as the branch, the URL, the tags, and
so forth. But locally,
we have access to my host name on
my machine,
the user that built it, the time,
the inputs
and then the subject context all there and
available for you to introspect. So so far,
we've worked with container images,
publishing the evidence to the public record, and
storing information and cache
locally. But what if we wanna keep that
somewhere that is a bit more transparent and
visible to our organization, our clients, our customers,
and so forth. So let's do a valid
BOM test salsa.
Only this time,
we'll scan a git repository.
Mongoexpressmongoexpress.git.
Now, I've already run this then the cache
is already available locally, so we got a
cache hit and it doesn't need to do
it again.
Sweet. However,
that cache still lives on my local machine.
So let's push it and store it inside
of an OCIR effect. So this time we'll
run Valiant Bomb,
a test alpha,
and we're going to scan
my GHCR
Rawkode
clustered
v two image
and enable
the OCI
store. And make sure you spell Salsa correctly.
So much like all the other commands, this
is pulling down an image, collecting the evidence.
However,
this time, it's going to store the evidence
remotely
on the OCI registry
next to where the container image actually lives.
And that's done. You trust me. Right?
Let's head over to GHCR
where we can click on packages,
clustered,
and here we go.
My v two image was built a year
ago. However, less than a minute ago, we
published our attestation to the OCI registry.
This can now be pulled, inspected,
and verified again
by my team, my organization,
my suppliers, my customers, and so forth. Awesome.
So one last thing. So far, all we've
really covered is salsa attestation,
which gives us confidence or a record of
where things were built, how they were built,
and when they were built. But Valens
supports
all of those run times and languages that
we covered on the graph at the start.
So let's take a look building a bill
of materials for a Go project,
And let's keep this topical. I'm in a
directory and taking a look at Blue Sky
Go SDK or program called Indigo.
From here, we can run valent BOM where
we specify that we want to run this
against the current working directory. This has already
been run, so it was pretty fast and
we can see that the analysis has already
been completed.
And the output has been stored and the
generic valent cache. Let's run this one more
time.
And just to make things a bit easier
for ourselves, we'll set the output directory
to BOM. Now we can go inside the
BOM directory
where we see we have our cache dot
JSON much like we had with the Salsa
association.
We can cat this and pipe it through
j q, but we also have this other
fail,
which is the complete bill of materials. Now
when you do a test salsa, this is
a encrypted payload.
However,
without a test salsa, we have all of
the information and the bill of materials available.
Let's do this one more time, but put
it through a pager. Here, I can see
that the default output format is CycloneDX.
We can see the components involved as part
of this bill of materials,
including the GET repository and so forth. However,
what's really cool is when we scroll down,
we get into all the dependencies
because Valen understands Go, understands Python, understands
Node and NPM.
We get a complete bill of materials including
all their dependencies,
the versions, and where they came from as
part of our bill of materials. So there
you have it. Valant is a pretty sweet
command line application that you can run locally
in CI or even as a mission controller
with Kubernetes.
It allows you to build attestation for Salsa
and Cyclone and a build of materials in
various formats,
looking into various runtimes programming languages and even
context such as local, GitHub, GitLab and so
forth. So go check it out. Improve your
supply chain posture today. Go have some fun.